all right i want to start today with
sort of like a funny little story that's
actually not really that funny and um it
says a lot about senate uh republican
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
so yesterday on the show i kind of gave
you guys my perspective on this joe
biden has said he will choose a black
woman to the supreme court
and um the question was posed to mitch
mcconnell in the context of
you know sort of an expectation that
there may be funny business with mitch
mcconnell when it comes to joe biden's
eventual supreme court pick and so on
and so forth and it doesn't even matter
mitch mcconnell was asked how many black
women work for him
and um first mitch mcconnell twice
appears not to hear or understand the
question until the reporter pulls his
mask down and then later he says he
doesn't actually know because he doesn't
have a quota for black women which was a
very cynical attempt to turn the
question back as a racist question and
it completely backfires so let's look at
the first clip here is mitch mcconnell
twice asked about how many black women
are on his staff and he can't hear it
doesn't understand it how many black
women do you have on staff and how are
they informing your decision to move
forward with the scoliosis nomination
and same question to the other senators
how many what how many black women do
you have on your staff and are they
informing your decision on how to move
forward with this golden nomination
and same question to the other senators
okay so mitch mcconnell asks that the
reporters uh uh mask be pulled down
that's pablo manriquez
um from latino rebels so when when pablo
asked the question for the third time
mitch mcconnell responds to try to make
the question seem racist how many black
women do you have on staff and how are
they informing your decision yeah
yeah actually i haven't checked we don't
have a racial quota in my office but
i've had a number of african-american
employees both male and female over the
years in all kinds of different
positions including speech writer
so um
he doesn't know and he wants to make it
seem like asking that is racist because
i have no quota and if you're asking me
how many black women i have on staff you
know sort of like a binder's full of
women mitt romney type incident you're
you're that's a it's an inappropriate
question
it's a bizarre answer because senate
senate staffs are not so big
that you would have no idea it's like
are are there do you have any black
women that that work for you and we can
argue it doesn't matter we can argue
it's an appropriate question like i'm
not saying those things but that's an
argument we can have
but is this at all believable like it's
not it's not racist to just know the
answer
um you know if someone came to me and
said sir
uh when you worked at circuit city
how many black women worked with you
this was 20 years ago there were about
80 people that i worked with at circuit
city i would be able to tell you it was
three or four
that was a long time ago and i'm saying
three or four because i don't remember
whether
all four worked there with me at the
same time or whatever the case may be
but there were there were three or four
black women that worked with me at
circuit city 20 years ago if you and
it's not just about
black women if you said how many asian
men worked with me as part of my
internship remember when i got licensed
for life insurance and i sold life
insurance for a summer and i hated it
and i knew financial working and
financial planning is not for me you say
how many asian men were part of the
intern cadre with you i can tell you
with certainty there were none
there were none there was no quota
it's not racist to remember it it just
kind of like is what it is and so when
mitch mcconnell says it's a total
backfire if if the question was how many
black women were at your last political
rally where there were 500 people
saying i don't know i didn't it's it's
completely reasonable and plausible
uh if you say you know if you say david
how many native americans were with you
in fifth grade in your fifth grade class
there were none i know that there were
no native americans in my fifth grade
class there were
curricula about native americans and it
was a topic that there were no native
americans in the class it was a topic of
discussion it's not racist to remember
that it's just very hard when asked
these questions you know and and part of
the funny thing is
the right
uh loves to say
and they are correct
that as humans
and and many on the left say this too
but the right also says they say as
humans
you can't not notice certain attributes
when you meet someone without prejudice
you're immediately judging
am i talking to an old person or a young
person right you're not going to have a
conversation with someone and then they
go was that a kid or was that an adult i
i don't know i don't see age it's like
no of course you do
you would know whether that was someone
between 50 and 70 or a little kid you
would know that you're immediately
evaluating gender and sometimes you
could be wrong sure but you're you're
immediately evaluating it
you're generally speaking evaluating
race it doesn't mean you can always tell
is it was that person
indian american or not it doesn't mean
you're always doing it accurately but
you're instantly making these
evaluations about people so the right
loves to say that
and they're correct that these things
happen it doesn't make you racist to
notice those things but then mitch
mcconnell has asked like from your
senate staff how many black women do you
have you go i don't know no i mean we
don't have any quotas it implies the
question is racist the last part of this
is
if he really doesn't know
everybody who works for him that's
another level of sort of like
cringe-worthy narcissism which is maybe
a topic for another day but like if it's
true that he doesn't know
it's very very strange and it could be
one of those like we don't ever look at
the senator sort of things
i actually don't think that that's what
it is i think
i think the answer is zero
and mitch mcconnell was just attempting
to make the question seem racist
yesterday i played a clip for you from
radical
republican congresswoman marjorie taylor
green's
off the wall interview with alex jones
that's the same alex jones who said
thank god you're not david pakman thank
your lucky stars every day you're not
dave pagman exactly that's the same alex
jones who now has attacked our bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad okay so
during that interview i didn't see this
clip until after yesterday's show during
that very same interview with marjorie
taylor green
alex jones actually suggests to marjorie
taylor green what about you running for
president and marjorie taylor greene
doesn't say i'm not interested take a
look at this can we get you to run for
president in
the next few years because i think i
think you're one of the few people
that would probably have a better voting
record and have a better chance than
winning on even trump or maybe a
green desantis
ticket oh my god
well alex i don't know what's going to
happen i'm a very strong supporter of
president trump but in the future we'll
we'll definitely see what happens by the
way that's code for i would absolutely
do it but i'm not going to run against
trump what the people think about
something like that but we need a green
agenda
build back better with president greene
well we my agenda would be all for this
country i just i love our country and i
hate absolutely hate what the federal
government has done to the american
people um sure absolutely before cnn
spins that i'm not actually endorsing
their fake green agenda their comments
agenda it's a play on words yes it's a
play on words now laugh at your own
peril
laugh at your own peril because many of
us laughed off trump but you know why we
did because we overestimated the
intelligence and common sense and
critical thinking skills of the
republican electorate
we overstated it and if you overestimate
the intelligence of the republican voter
you get burned and so if you laugh at
the idea of marjorie taylor green as at
least as the republican nominee
just remember that donald trump did it
now we almost have to hope i mean this
is crazy we have to hope that
republicans on principle would not elect
a woman president but sadly this is
exactly the type of woman they might
elect
she can be
their
proof
about how wrong we are about their
sexism and misogyny in the entire thing
and i i hate to say this
but
most likely
whoever replaces trump as the republican
frontrunner if trump is pushed out if
trump doesn't run it's a different thing
but if trump is pushed out
it will probably be someone who's even
worse than trump and i know that it's
hard to imagine but
when the party is so radical
and 50 60 percent of its voters are so
whacked out
they still want trump to run at this
point in time
they're not going to say let's choose
someone more rational and sober than
donald trump
if anything it would go in the opposite
direction and in particular when policy
no longer matters
and a very high
priority
for these folks is pick someone that
will trigger the liberals that's that's
a top priority for who they pick
um it's certainly plausible they would
go with somebody like marjorie taylor
green if it came to it i mean remember
evangelicals
didn't care about how obviously
non-religious trump was
and how he didn't go to church and he
was pro-choice until he decided to run
for president and all this stuff and
eventually the evangelicals came over
and supported donald trump uh the family
values people didn't care about the
number of wives and divorces and affairs
that donald trump they eventually came
to came over and part of it was we don't
like hillary obviously and part of it
was let's trigger the liberals they
would be so triggered by this so i would
not laugh off the possibility not of a
margaery taylor green presidency
although once you get to be the nominee
anything can happen as we saw in 2016
but i would not laugh off the
possibility of a marjorie taylor green
uh nomination
among the republican party
let me know what you think find me on
twitter at d pacman we'll take a quick
break and be back
what a friday show we have for you today
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpackman.com
welcome back to the show remember that
the david pakman show does depend on
viewers and listeners like you to
support us through the membership
program alex jones has now attacked the
membership program he has disparaged the
bonus show and so we need to fight alex
jones and say no
he will not restrict membership
he will not restrict the bonus show you
can sign up at joinpakman.com
and you can use the coupon code wow 22
to get a sizable discount we are going
to hear from some people in the audience
we now take calls via discord at
davidpakman.com
discord
let's go first to an old friend i hope i
still remember how to pronounce your
name
this is
alisa medua from dallas did i do okay
uh you did all right i appreciate the
attempt and it's great to talk to you
again sir yes uh thank you sir what's
going on
yeah so um i've noticed that on the
campaign trail for the midterms uh many
candidates including josh mandel who i
don't recommend you looking up
um they're promoting uh bitcoin and
cryptocurrency
and they're talking about how it's going
to be like good for the future so i'd
just like to get your thoughts on that
yeah i don't have any emotional
attachment to or opposition to bitcoin
or cryptocurrency um this is you know
there's a lot of people who are feeling
the need to be extremely black and white
on crypto my view on crypto is as
follows it's been around over a decade
at this point in time and while uh it is
still very volatile i see no reason to
think that it's going to go away if
scalability is addressed and transaction
fees are addressed
um i believe it's going to be around and
i believe it will there will be more
adoption due to the level of risk
financially that crypto represents the
volatility
my personal decision without advising
anyone else is i years ago put roughly
three to five percent of my assets in
cryptocurrency that's done very well for
me but i also recognize it could do
poorly and that's why i only put in
three to five percent i am not super
interested in the people who either say
crypto is the solution to everything or
crypto is the devil i don't think either
is true and i think we've got to step
away from these like overly emotional
assessments of it
yeah i agree with you and i'm in the
same boat with crypto i just have i'm
not sure if it's like three percent
right now but like i'm kind of like
starting out with investing so i'm
probably gonna hold off on
buying crypto for now and just like
focus on just etfs but um yeah thank you
very much for taking my call and i hope
that i'll have time next time to call
you again i hope so all right oh from
dallas always great to hear from him
and kicking us off with some very very
strong topics let's go to alexander the
texan next alexander the texan you're on
the air
hi david can you hear me i can hear you
fine
okay uh
i was just wondering so
there seems to be a subset of leftists
in america that i would call america bad
leftist okay what do you think what do
you think drives their uh
i would call it propagandistic
uh coverage of like this russia ukraine
situation
i think you'd really have to ask them i
mean i think if your starting point is
the u.s is uniquely bad
then that's your hammer right and so
everything will look like a nail russia
ukraine is an opportunity to say the u.s
is bad
um
uh venezuela is an opportunity to say
the u.s is bad cuba is an opportunity
you know if if you're committed to the
hammer everything looks like a nail and
i think i think it's that
for some specific people
we've later found out about financial
ties to some authoritarian regimes and
so for some people there may be a
financial aspect to it but i don't think
there's anything
particularly hidden you know i mean i
think it's just a lot for a lot of
people it's like hey look at this
terrible thing china's doing yeah but
the us also does bad things
right yeah and i criticize those but
we're talking about china right now i
think you get the point right and so i
think i think it's quite it's quite that
simple that's all it is
okay yeah well that's really all that i
wanted i'll let you move on to the next
caller i value your opinion david and
thank you for taking my call all right
and are you are you bunkering hunkering
down for the upcoming winter storm there
in texas
uh yes i am and i'm hoping that we have
a little bit better luck this year and a
little more competence on the part of uh
yeah my particular municipality that's
what i'm hoping and this aid as a whole
that's what i'm hoping for all right uh
stay safe down there alexander thank you
thank you very much david all right
alexander the texan checking in
let's go
uh next to oh let's go to our old old
friend issa from london issa how are you
i'm good how are you i'm doing well and
what what's going on all coveted
guidelines are being ended there is that
right
yeah that's right yeah they they
scrapped everything
but you know i don't know if you keep up
with uk politics much
there's you know much much bigger issues
with our government so
right now
a whole whole lot going on you know yes
indeed and i mean are you referring to
the boris johnson coveted party stuff or
what specifically yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know there's there's new new things
from the past that you know get brought
up every day but today's topic i guess
yeah is johnson yep
um but go ahead yeah sorry
um yeah i was gonna say this uh a
thought i was having um aaron rodgers
said his stuff about uh people brewing
against green bay because of his vaccine
status yes i think i feel like what
happened to rogers is the same thing
that happened to rogan but rogan
happened on a much larger scale and what
i mean is
he came out and he said all his stuff
right about vaccines and how he wouldn't
take them and how he encourages young
people not to get them
and then he caught over it
and
everyone clowned him for that so badly
that it kind of led him to snap
if you if you understand where i'm
coming from it basically clipped him
over the edge
and ever since then
his
whole persona his personality has been
covered vaccines leftists woke mob
cancel culture mainstream media cnn and
even even the guests he brings on his
shows
they're just people that he can circle
jerk with about how right he is to
reaffirm himself
so
yeah i was just wondering what you think
about that well i ended up saying you
know when i talked about aaron rodgers
the nfl football player saying people
were rooting against us because of my
vaccine status i gave and i said that's
true to some degree i gave it more
thought
i think that there's actually more to it
i think people some people were rooting
against aaron rodgers
because the entire covid thing made him
look like a know-it-all prick and that's
what a lot of people were kind of
reacting to more so than the fact that
he's unvaccinated per
se yeah
in terms of the rogan stuff i mean
listen
i know the guy a little bit
and
i believe him when he says
he's not trying to spread
disinformation he believes the stuff
that the guests say
i do believe that i i don't think he's
trying to spread this information
i just think he is and i think part of
it is
we know that since he's moved to texas
at least somewhat he hangs out with the
with the wacky republican governor greg
abbott you know he's in he's in a circle
where i think what's going on around him
is very reactionary and radical and even
without bad intentions i think he's just
been captured by a lot of the stuff i'm
not excusing anything he's done i think
the stuff that's gone out on his show is
terrible but i believe him when when he
says he's not malicious in trying to
spread this information i think it's
coming from a place of ignorance
yeah no of course yeah that's fair
enough i mean you've you've been on his
show twice you you know him so yeah
that's fair it just seemed to me
that ever since the whole kobe thing
happened his ego i guess has been
wounded deeply so it's possible i can't
speak to that but it's certainly
possible that that's what's going on
yeah
yeah
no yeah cool
all right lisa from london thank you so
much for the call great to hear from you
again of course
let's go next to
let's go to travis from manila is this
manila in the philippines
yes sir can you hear me yes i can are
you uh you an expat
yeah i'm just here for work okay
uh my question for you and thank you for
taking my call big fan pleasure um
considering and forgive me i i don't
have the poll in front of me but i just
seen a poll that said something like 80
of americans were just completely done
with any
or all coveted restrictions yeah would
it be wise politically for democrats to
move
in that direction
yes and i think that basically they
already are i mean i think the biden
white house hasn't yet really put out
anything
specific about like we're going to the
next phase here but i think many states
are thinking in that direction even like
i heard from family in in massachusetts
that
the school guidelines and you know it's
a republican governor in massachusetts
but it's it's you know liberal
legislature they're going in the
direction of normalizing a lot of school
stuff um i think i don't think the risk
is over to any degree um but i don't
know i don't think so either
but to be clear politically makes sense
yeah i you don't think it makes sense to
get rid of guidelines or you don't think
it makes sense to keep them
i don't make i i don't think it makes
sense to keep them right yeah no i'm
increasingly of that mindset and part of
it is
with cases going down so rapidly
and the belief that we're moving into
the endemic phase endemic doesn't mean
mild necessary necessarily you can have
something that's endemic and serious
it's just a question of like we were
talking about with vincent racaniello
two weeks ago what milestone are we
waiting for in terms of
omicron is we're well beyond the peak
and
um masking and vaccines
are
widely available everybody sort of knows
at this point the level of risk that you
have i it's a question of like what's
the next milestone we're waiting for if
we don't start easing off of stuff now
and making things more kind of personal
decisions
what do you think the answer to that
question is
i i mean i think it's
if there is another
variant that makes cases spike and it's
not significantly milder like if the
next variant truly is just a cold then i
think we don't do anything but if
there's a new variant that is just as
dangerous as the ones that we've had you
probably put some guidelines back on as
my sense
okay i i appreciate the time dave thank
you very much my pleasure thank you so
much for the call
uh let's go next to
jonathan from it's north something i
can't it's cut off jonathan from north
where are you from jonathan
hey
david uh great to talk to you first of
all
um i'm from north carolina okay i'm
actually from close to charlotte
beautiful
um
my question was regarding
people who have
sort of
undergone a bit of a change
ever since trump went into office yes um
for me it's a little personal because my
mom is kind of like
had like a complete personality change
and
my question is sort of
i guess
what do you think in the next like five
to ten years like
will be the impact of so many people
having this
complete 180
about like their viewpoint of life like
how will that affect
the way that the rest of the country
kind of reacts because we can definitely
see like
there's a lot of people who
that really have have
i don't really know how to put it into
words like just there's there's a lot of
people who have
completely changed yeah they're off the
deep end i mean here's the thing so let
me give you the worst case and then
we'll give you the optimistic
the worst case is that the sequel a over
the next 10 years of these newfound
radical reactionary trumpist types is
going to be disastrous for the country
because
increasingly they're going to be
you know the teachers in schools they're
going to be the people deciding what
gets taught and how in schools they're
going to be
i guess some nurses and doctors they're
going to be elected officials and that
is absolutely horrifying and that's the
pessimistic case and that's why we need
to even absent trump uh remain extremely
active to prevent these people from
gaining power the more optimistic
perspective would be
they
were not many of them were not involved
in politics before trump
and without trump they might get bored
and stop being involved in politics
anymore
again
and to me that's a more optimistic
scenario that they just kind of get
bored with it all and go away
yeah
okay well thank you very much for taking
my question and i really appreciate what
you do and
enjoy your show thank you so much i
appreciate the call
let's talk next where do we want to go
next there's a lot of folks here
what about um
let's go to
is it tealer from
saint uh where is it saint saint louis
is it
taylor t lure
yes it is uh it is from st louis i
bungled up my name but uh
i wanted to ask about
what what is what is up with the
advertisements on your channel with uh
always involving crypto
like what do you mean
most of our advertisers have nothing to
do with crypto
um you always you always do these uh
single video advertisements and
they're always sketchy cryptocurrency
sort of things
um
i think we did one in the last few weeks
can you give me an example of it being
sketchy crypto
um one of them was uh
one of them was an nft thing which was
the most recent one and the other and
the other i don't exactly remember the
name is the name of but it ended up
um and ended up failing because of
numerous um
fec
uh warnings against it
okay please don't use push to talk we're
hearing the discord blings come through
um in terms of the nft so are you
talking about a crypto currency or now
you're saying it nft these are two
different things which one did you mean
uh i was meaning the i was meaning all
of them
okay but you so but is this call about
the the recent nft one or a
cryptocurrency because these are i can i
can't address them
generally if there's a specific
i guess we can i guess i guess you could
address the recent nft advertisement
because
a lot of people
do not
approve of
you advertising these things oh okay
yeah i mean listen we have advertisers
um we make clear when things are
sponsored or it's an advertiser i can't
think of any advertiser that i've not
had people complain about um when we
have
you know a serial company
people write in saying the cereal is
expensive and not very good and we
really shouldn't be associated with them
when we have a knife company people say
the type of steel the knives are made of
is no good when we
no we never have the perfect advertiser
and so what we're trying to do is
we run an ad program
we
have uh advertisers we mark things as
advertisements
we allow people to make decisions about
any advertiser that they want and
no there's no way everybody will be
happy with every advertiser that's for
sure
um okay
all right and then the individual hung
up okay
um all right let's go to the next
i figured there would be some kind of
dialogue but i guess not
let's go next to
let's go to rob from richmond rob you
are next
david can you hear me yes i can rob
hey so i think global warming the whole
conversation around it needs to be
changed a little bit i think it needs to
be more structured so
you know i
i think republicans and democrats can
get on the side of protecting
wildlife
environments
why don't we say like building kelp
forest
uh near the oceans brings habitats
but it also
helps drag co2 down
and it would do two things at once
but i think if you go to the minute it
can get republicans on board with it
i don't know i mean do republicans care
about dr i mean it's just not clear that
they um
i don't know that that would get them to
care presenting it in the terms you're
saying i mean it would be great if you
were right i just i've seen no evidence
that if we framed it the way you're
saying all of a sudden they care
i think i thought there was data that
they care about animal habitats and
especially moderates do
moderates probably do there's a lot of
right wingers who straight up say when i
hear about some seal or or a shrew
that's endangered i don't care in fact i
think there's clips of candace oh and
straight up saying it like i don't care
about
some salamander at all period and so i'm
not sure i think you're right that the
moderates would be more amenable to that
type of argument but i think they
already care more so that's those aren't
really the type of people we need to
convince
all right do you have a favorite album
by um soda esterio
no no not really
did you see my exchange with the 311
bassist on twitter is that why you're
asking no no no oh no no no that was
that was bomb by stereo sorry no i i now
i'm confused no i don't i don't have a
particularly a particular favorite album
favorite song
uh
no not even i'm not super familiar with
their music i just i have them in an
argentinian
uh playlist that a friend made and i
don't even know the names of the songs
because i just hear them
all right david thank you all right
thank you rob very much appreciate that
uh i really got called out there yeah
i'm not not well versed on the song
names all right let's take a quick break
if you're holding don't hang up because
we are going right back to the phones in
a moment
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
all right let's hear from a few more
people via discord
davidpakman.com slash discord
let's go next to alexander from
something that starts with p-a-l i can't
it's cut off where are you from
alexander
um
[Music]
um
i'm from a town called palm coast
okay palm coast
what's on yeah
it's in florida gotcha
and by the way i've never been on the
air before so i'm kind of nervous oh
don't worry you're doing great what's on
your mind
hey um
i wanted to come to ask you something
see if you could personally
um
answer this
um
um
you know
it's about these news
networks that everyone talks about yeah
what's the difference between fox news
newsmax and oan also known as one
america news well i think they become
more reactionary in exactly the order
you listed them fox newsmax oan in that
order
what do you mean reactionary more
unhinged extreme and uh cartoonish i
guess i would say like it oan to me
seems like it's out and out crazy where
there's people on it
like for example the anti-vaxx stuff on
fox
is a little more polished it's less
polished on newsmax and it's straight up
crazy on oan like i think i think that
that's uh that am i getting my point
across
um
i think so she's i i never really viewed
them as that and i'm i have a hard time
really distinguishing them oh okay yeah
i mean listen i will i will admit
that
fox has
done stuff in the last three months on
tucker's show for example related to
vaccines where tucker says you know tens
of thousands of people appear to have
died from the vaccine a statement that's
totally untrue that has even surprised
me
but as a general thing i find that
newsmax is crazier than fox and oan is
even crazier with even lower
journalistic standards to the extent
that they exist like i don't even think
newsmax has any of what they even
pretend is hard news whereas fox does
but it's biased you know
yeah i guess so i just
i don't know i i never really thought of
it like that because
i knew they were all kind of people
would like lump them in the same
category but i didn't know like they
were like
that different from each other and how
they report on news and yeah they're
they're definitely in the same category
but i think oan is uh is is the absolute
crazy like you mean like
fox news is the quote-unquote my oldest
and then uh one america news is like the
most unhinged the most
off the walls bonkers
news channel that's how i would put it
yeah hey alexander i know you said
you're you're in florida are you from
new york originally
what the
sorry what
so i said what the because my whole
family is oh okay yeah no you just have
a very noticeable new york accent and
you sound like michael cohen you know
really yeah no
that's interesting to know um
um i'm pretty sure that was it
actually uh uh this i'm gonna make this
very very quick
but there's one more thing
that i feel like i need to ask okay um
so
you hear about um
what's it called it's the thing with the
um
alexander i've got a lot of people
holding so i'm gonna let you go i really
appreciate the call and the multiple
questions and it's been a true pleasure
having you on
let me go next to steve from chicago
illinois steve how are you
i'm doing good how are you i'm doing
well sorry
what's on your mind no i asked you it's
okay
uh just a reactionary um
uh i had a couple things you can cut me
off i'm going for too long though sure
um quick question um i know you did a
video on
um anti-semitism with tucker and i think
he was talking to godfeld yep um with
george soros um i i i felt like you were
just kind of saying it was anti-semitic
for
saying stuff they didn't like what
george soros was doing i don't know if
you can explain it a little better it
kind of seemed like
they
were kind of like just like talking
about how he uses money and then that's
like anti-semitic nope that's not at all
what it's definitely not what i said and
it's also not what i meant so i'm glad
to have the opportunity to say more um
george soros at this point is basically
a placeholder boogeyman
for is it boogeyman or bogeyman i'm not
actually do you know which it is
it's bogeyman boogeyman okay george
soros has become a sort of anti-semitic
placeholder boogeyman
for um uh for code
for rich jews in many cases and so
whether tucker specifically intended it
to be that or not um
the the soros ruining america with his
money is just a tired anti-semitic trope
which which makes no sense i mean he's a
91 year old guy at this point and the
idea that he would be hell-bent on
destroying america in any way
simply doesn't pass the sniff test and
so you really have to look at context
and
everything about
that piece
reeked of the sort of let's find someone
to blame and we're not going to mention
that he's jewish but it's this this
trope of the rich jew
ruining and controlling things for his
benefit it's just a very old trope it
doesn't mean what tucker was
specifically saying is
anti-semitic okay i mean um i guess i
can kind of see you were saying i guess
i just i don't think that segment was
too anti-semitic and i was no no and
that's the thing is you have to under
that it's by design that
if
it coded language and coded tropes are
designed where if you don't know the
milieu within which it exists you
wouldn't see it for what it is a part of
i i get the coded language i just don't
think they're like using coding language
in that scenario there
for there i guess i just disagree with
you on that yes i don't mean literally
language i don't literally like
anti-semitic okay
what i guess would be what whoopi
goldberg said this week on the view i
don't know if you've been able to touch
that or not yep i think what whoopi
goldberg says is this said it was
disgusting and it unfortunately plays
into so
the george soro stuff is the type of
anti-semitism you see from the right the
whoopee stuff about the holocaust wasn't
about race
and a jew you know it goes to the jews
are not an oppressed minority
soft anti-semitism that's more common on
the left so i called it out on the
wednesday show absolutely
ah sorry i must i must have missed i was
just wondering no that's cool um about
that and uh if you can call me you can
call me off if you want but the last
question i had was i know i've seen some
stuff on you on uh gerrymandering from
the right i was wondering if you had any
comment on what's been going on what
they're proposing for new york which
seems very ex uh
on the side of gerrymandering extreme
for restriction
my view my view on this is not partisan
my view on this is gerrymandering is bad
and we need a system
that is a non-partisan system there's
four or five different ones that have
been proposed i'm agnostic about which
as long as it's better than what we have
now
and i also recognize that for as long as
gerrymandering is possible if
republicans are going to do it as badly
as they can
i have to also recognize that democrats
must take opportunities to do it because
otherwise they lose everything
all right i guess i can see that is i
guess it just probably won't ever stop
then if both sides can keep on doing it
then well remember the mechanism to stop
the gerrymandering is a different one
than the mechanism by which
gerrymandering takes place so you can
both realize
that if either they gerrymander or we do
it's better if it's us you can recognize
that and at the same time work to put in
place a nonpartisan redistricting
commission you can do both
um yeah i guess like i don't know two
evils don't make a right uh in my mind i
agree and i'm not saying they're saying
for the power yeah um but i appreciate
you taking my call and answering the
questions and kind of giving me more of
an outlook of what you're saying with
the whole uh soros
aspect on that thank you very much all
right thank you steve very much
appreciate it great uh great to hear
from you
uh why don't we go next
to ben from los angeles ben you're on
the air
hello david hello first time caller how
are you i'm doing well
um that's awesome um
but i had a question about uh biden
putting in so i've got to ask you to
either or both turn off your discord
notifications and don't use push to talk
because every 10 seconds we're hearing a
discord bling and the odd i get 20
emails every time it happens so please
please please um uh
see if you can do that where do you do
that by the way i'm sorry
where would you do that so if you go
into settings under notifications turn
them all off and then under audio video
settings turn off push to talk
beautiful please proceed governor
okay so biden just sent in 3 000 troops
in into
poland and around the
ukraine
area
um i'm just wondering if you think that
it's gonna escalate any further
uh at this at this point it's anyone's
guess
um indeed the united states is sending 3
000 troops to eastern europe in the
forthcoming days uh poland and romania
there were already 8 500 u.s troops on
alert um at the end of uh january i
don't think um
any prediction i mean listen
anyone can predict this will escalate or
this will not escalate i don't think we
know because i think it fundamentally
comes down to what putin is actually
planning and i don't pretend to know
what putin is actually planning
okay thank you for that what do you
think
i do have one one last different
question so
um pfizer last week said that they are
testing an omicron
uh variant of the vaccine yes uh
i'm wondering is as we progress into
2022 and 2023
will um
what it means to be fully vaccinated
change based on that so i know some
colleges and
some small states and some events do
require you to get boosted
um i'm wondering if
over time we will
the
basically the premise of being fully
vaccinated will require like four shots
i think um much like with other things
it'll just it'll be are you up to date
on your shots it'll be it'll be less
about the number of doses it'll just be
are you up to date so you know as as
covid continues to evolve it would make
sense that for example two years from
now
the vaccine that would be considered up
to date is going to be different than
the one based on the live virus that's
the vaccine that's been around now for
more than a year so um you know i i
think it'll just as as we get beyond the
pandemic phase into the endemic phase
and vaccines like the flu shot will be
modified it's sort of like if i say yes
i got the flu shot five years ago you
would say well you're not up to date
because that was for the strains then we
have a we have an up-to-date flu shot i
think it'll just change to that rather
than a number of doses
do you think how like there's people who
don't get flu shots like every year do
you think i'm sure the same is going to
happen with the
covid absolutely vaccines no doubt um do
you think like states
and
different
places will care about
um how up-to-date you are as we as we
move into the endemic phase
uh that will depend on whether it
becomes significantly less severe or not
and i think different states will have a
different perspective but if it
continues to be severe
then there will be states that will
continue to insist on vaccine
requirements if it really does become
milder and becomes like the flu or more
mild then i think it will be handled
like the flu vaccine which will be uh
much less strict but i i think we just
we're just not going to know for a while
let's see yeah
okay thank you so much david all right
thank you there's ben from los angeles
that's going to do it for today i'm so
glad i was able to speak to so many of
you we will take calls again and we'll
take a quick break and be right back
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right let's get into this week's
mailbag you can email info
davidpakman.com if you have something to
say please don't abuse the email
unfortunately the more the reason i keep
saying this is
we now have
over a hundred different people that are
emailing us so regularly almost using
our email address like a blog free free
association
um of whatever's going through their
minds
we have over a hundred people whose
emails are automatically filtered into a
folder that we never look at unless law
enforcement says please forward us to
your communications with these people
which sometimes happens but please don't
abuse it okay don't let's let's uh keep
it let's keep it respectful all right
let's jump right into it here
um here's someone who sounds reasonable
why aren't you talking about the biden
crime family dragging us into war the
berezma deal with hunter biden is going
to have the usa in war with russia
and because biden colluded with russia
gave them the pipeline we have no
bargaining and we're over a barrel this
will not be a just war but an evil war
of course you won't because you're
nothing but a communist propagandist a
liar lying
your damn ass off
um brutal attack brutal attack on the
english language here
i actually think
that um
it's legally a requirement that if you
write hate mail you have to use the
wrong
your versus your like you apostrophe
it's it seems to be a legal requirement
from what i'm getting if we end up in a
conflict with russia
it will not be the united states alone
and it will not be because of hunter
biden
i don't know that there's that much else
to say here
and so i won't say anything else
next message only commie idiots like you
think democrats are actually good
in one line you can pack such
disinformation
and this one is funny because i'm
neither a communist
nor a democrat and as those who have
been following the show for some time
know
i get criticized by the actual
socialists because i'm not a socialist
and then the right says i am a socialist
or in this case a communist in terms of
democrats are good
i think
i'm one of the most
consistently
indifferent to the democratic party i'm
not
as actively hostile to it as others are
but i don't care at all about the
democratic party i've never been a
democrat
i see the democratic party as having as
its number one goal
self-preservation they want to stay in
power and i really couldn't care less
about the democratic party as far as
democrats are good if you're talking
about how i vote i look at each race
i look at the candidates and i pick the
one that i think would do the least
damage and the most good it's it's
it's almost boring
but no not a communist not a democrat
either michael wrote in about religious
exemptions michael says hey david i just
watched your segment about the
serviceman who was asking for the
religious exemption for the vaccine he
said something about the pedigree of
technology or something and then ended
with convicted in the spirit
then you rightly pointed out all the
other vaccines that service members are
required to get and asked where in the
bible or other religious texts does it
say
one list is fine but the covid vaccine
is bad
mike writes the only thing he said that
he could argue to those who speak his
language going back to amanda montel's
cult language concepts is convicted in
the spirit
as a recent convert away from
christianity i still recognize the coded
language of the group this means in
short god is telling him not to get the
vaccine and that is his justification
for religious exemption not any text any
rational person wouldn't be able to
follow his logic but most in christendom
would that's very interesting so it's
sort of like a get out of jail free card
um if you say well my reli i'm against
it for religious reasons and then
someone like me shows up and i underst i
got a very nice email from a lawyer who
said
legally it's problematic to say show us
where your religion says that i get it
but someone like me shows up in a
conversation and i go oh
where does your religion say that it
seems that this i'm convicted by the
spirit not to get the vaccine
is sort of like a
get out of jail free catch all where you
can drop that in and it could basically
just be god told me
god told me not to get it and of course
that puts us in the realm of
indefeasible well i don't know whether
whatever this person thinks god told
them
we can't really prove or disprove one
way or the other
many of you writing in about the recent
word salads
from jordan peterson
and one such person was kim kim wrote in
and said hey david regarding jordan
peterson's incoherent biblical rant i
believe it was his attempt to explain
that the bible as we know it today
is a collection of books for example the
book of matthew is a book
that's included in the bible i think you
were right when you said that his word
salad tricks people into thinking he's
smarter than they are
peterson says enough logical
well-thought-out comments to bait his
audience this interview is obviously not
well thought out i'm referring to clips
of him from years ago but once he hooks
his listeners he leads them down the
in-cell pipeline that creates school
shooters that's very very aggressive and
i suspect
not completely without merit
but um yeah the the
the tough thing about jordan peterson
is he always did the word salads and
they were always very borderline in
terms of being
sort of interesting
and being wacky disjointed delusions and
i think it's it's only gotten like five
percent worse but it was so borderline
to begin with that now it's very clearly
over the line that that's sort of my
sense of it um and we we've got some
more jordan peterson stuff
uh coming up to talk about
rodney wrote in
about me
leaving the country
and
again
sort of a misunderstanding rodney wrote
this is why sometimes i'm like i
shouldn't even talk about certain things
because it will be so misunderstood
rodney said david my wife and i are
proud to be members who joined without
accepting a discount so we could further
your broadcast experience thank you
rodney i appreciate that we enjoy your
program very much and rarely miss a show
you've talked about how it's necessary
to take these crazy right wingers such
as matt gates and newt gingrich
seriously there are probably a few who
do not but i think most of your
listeners recognize the seriousness of
what these people are saying and what
they will do if they get the opportunity
what would you have us do now that you
know we are taking them seriously we
would not vote for them ever what else
can we do we are ready
so if things become bad in this country
you're gonna leave or perhaps i should
say if things get worse
most of us do not have the means to just
leave even if we wanted to do so it's a
little disheartening to realize that is
your intention it's like that old
expression when the going gets tough the
tough get going out of the country it's
kind of like abandoning your teammates
in my view until then keep up the good
work
let me say
again
i have no plan to leave the country i
have no plan to leave the country i
would love to spend more time
in the place i was born argentina
and maybe after the pandemic it'll be a
possibility
but i have no plan to leave my
immediate family is in the united states
my work is in the united states
most everybody i know is in the united
states i have no plan to leave the
question was if it got so bad you felt
you had to leave where would you go and
i listed the places
that's all
i'm not abandoning everybody
i have no plan to leave and i shouldn't
even have brought it up
uh okay next email mike says just admit
that you're a democrat already
you claiming that you're not a democrat
is the equivalent of tim poole claiming
he isn't a republican i don't know
anything about tim poole's party
registration
i i just don't so i can't talk about tim
poole
when i claim i'm not a democrat i'm just
telling you the truth
i've never been a democrat
i don't care about the democratic party
as an institution
i believe as i said
ten minutes ago in this segment
uh that the democratic party's main goal
is its own self-preservation
not the good of the average person
so i would be lying if i said i was a
democrat now
mostly
in the modern era
in partisan elections i'm opting to vote
for the democrat but i don't do anything
with the democratic party
i don't donate to it i don't fundraise i
don't care about it so when i say i'm
not a democrat i'm just telling you the
truth all right here's the last one and
this one is
as crazy as anything i have ever
received
jj wrote to me
did you know biden made sure the
hospitals stay bankrupted by making it
so the water runs on electricity
that makes it so water for hospitals no
longer free
the same with the paper towel dispensers
almost everything got hooked up to
electricity
there are zero hospitals in america i
didn't know that the doctor no longer
check the suction cup part of the vagina
so females might die from a tampon
being stuck
in their bodies you know i have to say
the other day i wrote i drove by some
places where there used to be hospitals
all i saw was suction cups the hospitals
are gone so maybe jj is on to something
no in all seriousness
um
this is this is scary this is scary
wacky i don't know what jj is talking
about we've got a great bonus show for
you today sign up at joinpakman.com
you'll get instant access and remember
you can send me your thoughts that may
be featured in the mailbag
info
davidpakman.com we'll see you on the
bonus show or otherwise monday